vous qui scrutez l'opinion toute la
journée on entend Olivier Biscay
Emmanuel Boulan nous dire que la
mobilisation s'annonce suivie est-ce que
vous sentez dans l'opinion que la le
refus de cette réforme que la colère
contre cette réforme est en train de
monter on sent en tout cas que la
légitimité de la contestation est
inaltique 63% des Français soutiennent
le mouvement aujourd'hui soit
directement soit par procuration on
était autour de 65% pour le premier
mouvement donc on reste sur des niveaux
équivalents et surtout on a toujours la
même part de Français qui nous disent
quand bien même il y aurait des blocages
quand bien même le mouvement se
prolongerait je continuerai à le
soutenir donc voilà la légitimité est
vraiment dans la contestation
aujourd'hui dans dans l'opinion le
gouvernement étant très décrié
une grande partie de l'Est de la France
on l'a dit évidemment tous les jours
vous avez des remontées de ces Français
qu'est-ce que vous sentez de la colère
du pays et de la mobilisation contre
cette réforme effectivement on a vu
toutes les zones au couvertes par le
groupe Ebra une mobilisation souvent
record c'est les termes qui venaient
soit les records de 2010 avaient été
battus ou même dépasser le fait surtout
que dans des villes moyennes des petites
villes il y avait des manifestations on
a vu des des cortèges dans un village vu
qui colle d'Alsace intervillers il y
avait une manifestation au bonnet due
forme de 70 personnes dans d'autres
villes comme Épinal on a les records de
2010 qui ont été battus avec 5000
personnes dans la rue donc on voit en
fait aussi que c'est plus seulement les
grandes métropoles voilà qui a quelque
chose qui se passe en fait donc bon
quand on entend il y a cette idée de
Burn Out collectif alors on parle des
services publics des déserts médicaux de
la hausse du prix de l'énergie enfin
c'est vrai qu'il y a un climat qui fait
que quelque part la recette réforme est
perçue comme un peu la goutte d'eau qui
fait déborder le vase et on voit dans
ces cortèges des familles des poussettes
des gens du privé des gens du public
comme je t'ai expliqué et donc voilà ça
effectivement il y a quelque chose qui
semble se passer dans ces préfectures ou
sous-préfecture enfin ville un peu un
peu moins importante que les grandes
métropoles classiques où sont mobilisés
les sur ces mauvais et c'est important
parce que dit claire c'est vrai qu'on
l'a constaté le 19 janvier la
mobilisation elle est pas que dans les
grandes villes et elle est même forte
voire très forte dans les villes
moyennes dans les petites villes
qu'est-ce que ça dit
Erwan de l'état de l'opinion c'est
plutôt la démonstration de force de la
contestation et un effet cocotte-minute
c'est vrai qu'il y a un ensemble de
colère des Français qui viennent
s'exprimer aujourd'hui mais qui rallie
aussi on l'a vu avec les boulangers au
début du mois qui rallie énormément de
contestations et notamment celle de la
vie chère mais dans le moment actuel et
cette Français sur dix disait que la
mobilisation du 19 janvier avait été une
réussite mais pour cette raison là c'est
que finalement on a vu un rejet diffus
sur le territoire national et ça montre
l'ampleur de la contestation et du rejet
il a force de la mobilisation donc c'est
ce point là qui est important aussi
c'est la solidité de la mobilisation
face au projet de réforme de retraite
qui montre qu'on est vraiment dans une
phase conflictuelle et d'incompréhension
entre l'exécutif et les Français avec un
exécutif qui est dans un enjeu et de
rétablir les finances publiques à
travers une réforme des retraites et les
Français qui sont dans un enjeu de
défense d'un acquis social donc il y a
cette conflit d'enjeux ce conflit
d'enjeux avec des Français qui ont
l'impression d'être purement et
simplement légitime pour défendre cette
cause qu'il les rallie à travers le pays
c'est vraiment cette diffusion sur les
territoires nationales qui renforce le
sentiment d'un mouvement d'ampleur et
c'est très mobilisation c'est très forme
des retraites est-ce qu'elle est le
centre de cette mobilisation ou est-ce
que finalement elle est la goutte d'eau
qui fait déborder le vase de la colère
chez beaucoup de Français aujourd'hui
elle est le centre de la mobilisation on
n'est pas dans une phase de coagulation
ou de convergence des luttes on a vu que
les jeunes s'alliaient à certains
défilés on a eu le mouvement des
boulangers au début du mois mais pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore de
convergence des luttes ni de passerelle
utile entre l'augmentation du coût de la
vie et le projet des réformes de
retraite par exemple qui pourrait être
un élément de convergence cette
mobilisation dans les villes moyennes et
dans les petites villes quand elles
plancha est-ce qu'elle peut rappeler un
peu le mouvement des gilets jaunes ou
est-ce qu'on est dans dans deux choses
complètement différentes alors on a vu
quand même que tous ces cortèges avaient
été réalisés tout dans le calme donc
c'est qu'on n'est pas dans cette
attention ou violence voilà qui avait
quand même caractérisé assez vite les
mouvements des gilets jaunes notamment à
Paris et dans certaines grandes villes
on suit depuis un Velay ou il y a eu
aussi il a une manifestation très
importante donc on voit en fait quand on
interroge notamment les responsables
syndicalistes qui sont assez surpris en
fait souvent de l'ampleur de la
mobilisation même si ça peut faire
partie des éléments de langage mais tous
disent c'était au delà de nos espérances
et on compare en fait souvent c'est un
voilà c'est un étalon la mobilisation
pour le mouvement des gilets jaunes mais
c'est vrai que pour le moment je rejoins
ce que dit
Erwan on n'est pas dans cette dans cette
dynamique encore voilà on voit bien que
pour le moment le les syndicats
organisent ces mouvements c'est quand
même très structuré voilà on a vu c'est
qu'il y avait une journée de
mobilisation des gilets jaunes qui a
très peu pris avant avant cette séquence
sur les retraites on a craint voilà avec
la grève dans les transports qui étaient
à l'initiative voilà d'un collectif on a
vu les médecins aussi enfin c'est cette
déstructuration en tout cas cette façon
un peu plus diffuse du moment social là
on voit quand même il y a des journées
d'action qui sont organ donc pour le
moment on reste dans un cadre assez
classique de mobilisation on va voir
comment les syndicats prépare cette
journée de mobilisation après
Montpellier et Chalon-sur-Saône on
valait à Périgueux à Périgueux la
mobilisation a continué entre les deux
grosses journées d'action et gaz par
flamand justement est allé à la
rencontre des syndicalistes de la CFDT
voir comment ils ont préparé la journée
d'aujourd'hui
18h la nuit tombe sur Périgueux une
marche aux flambeau est organisée elle
réunit les 8 syndicats mobilisés contre
la réforme des retraites du côté des
équipes de la CFDT le ton est donné
c'est une admissible et c'est de
l'injustice par rapport au travailleur
et reculer de deux ans le départ à la
retraite pour certains salariés c'est
très très pénalisant et puis c'est
important d'être là aussi pour les
futurs pour les jeunes qui seront futurs
retraités s'ils ont droit encore c'est
pas sûr on va voir avec cette
déambulation dans les rues de la ville
organisée entre les deux grosses
mobilisations du mois de janvier le
syndicat souhaite montrer que tant que
le gouvernement ne bougera pas sur les
retraites la mobilisation continuera on
doit être tous unis jusqu'au bout sur
des journées très ponctuelles et des
actions entre pour expliquer dans les
entreprises dans les collectivités à nos
collègues qu'est-ce qui fait que ce
projet les pénalisant mais pour la CFDT
il y a une ligne à ne pas franchir le
mot d'ordre de l'intersyndicale c'est
des actions mais des actions qui
n'empêchent pas les gens d'aller
travailler par exemple puisque le budget
c'est de faire piller le gouvernement
pas d'empêcher les gens de travailler
le mardi 31 janvier dans toutes les
têtes tous souhaite faire flancher le
gouvernement
quelques heures plus tôt dans les locaux
du syndicat les militants s'activent
une perruque blanche d'accord
des coupes de tract gonflage de ballons
et surtout les pancartes qui vont être
brandi lors du défilé donc ça ce sont
les pancartes pour la manifestation de
mardi oui tout à fait ça fait partie des
pancartes pour la manifestation vous
voyez là on en a une sur Star Wars
encore un nouvel épisode la retraite à
860 ans je veux et on a donc Macron ta
réforme mets-toi là dans le côté obscur
parce que à la CFDT on est poli
comme service il faut que ça soit un peu
punchy un peu jeune parce que ça
s'adresse aussi aux jeunes donc qu'elle
soit un peu humoristique et puis surtout
je pense qu'il faut qu'elle passe le bon
message et qu'elle passe le message
surtout des travailleurs et des
travailleurs voilà Alexandra voit
également ce que le syndicat pourrait
améliorer lors des prochaines
mobilisations il faut aussi peut-être
qu'après la manifestation regrouper les
militants un peu plus communiquer
pourquoi on se retrouve pour un
casse-croûte voilà faire que la
manifestation soit aussi pour les
travailleurs et les travailleurs un
moment où ils se rencontrent où ils
peuvent parler de leur difficulté au
quotidien de leurs avis par rapport à
cette réforme de la retraite la grève
d'aujourd'hui devrait toucher tous les
secteurs transports énergie mais aussi
éducation plus de 200 manifestations
sont prévues dans le pays
éclair est-ce que on voit un la les
syndicats qui se prépare la mobilisation
les syndicats qui sont unis c'est la
première fois depuis 12 ans est-ce que
cette mobilisation elle relance aussi le
mouvement syndical et le syndicalisme
on voit que les en tout cas dans le
sondage dans le dévoiler la côte de
popularité des syndicats et pas
franchement en hausse en revanche
excusez moi de
qu'aujourd'hui ce que je disais tout à
l'heure ils sont ils sont moteurs dans
cette mobilisation et que pour le moment
on a une mouvement très structuré comme
je disais avec des appels voilà qui fait
que les gens se réunissent alors se
posera la question peut-être de
mobilisation les week-ends de voir si ça
change de forme on a bien entendu que
certains syndicats envisagaient des
agrèves reconductibles qui avaient
peut-être là un point un peu de rupture
entre différentes stratégies notamment
pendant les périodes des vacances
scolaires qui va aussi être un point
voilà sur l'adhésion des français ou pas
au mouvement même si voilà la cause de
la défense de la lutte contre cette
réforme des retraites sans dépasser
cette gêne occasionnée par la
mobilisation mais c'est vrai que voilà
je je pense qu'il est important pour le
dire voir dans la durée en fait sur le
mouvement
Erwan claire le disait il y a
effectivement des menaces de blocage
pendant les vacances scolaires de
journée d'action de grève reconductibles
est-ce que l'opinion peut se retourner
selon l'impact Cora ce Coran c'est
blocages sur son quotidien alors c'est
pas ce que nous disent les Français
aujourd'hui ils sont 6 sur 10 à nous
disent à nous dire combien même le
mouvement dure le mouvement dure pendant
les vacances de février je soutiendrai
toujours la contestation du projet de
réforme des retraites mais quand même
faut tenir compte d'une chose c'est que
aujourd'hui il y a du télétravail les
gens ne sont pas affectés pareil par des
grandes grèves le 19 janvier seulement
deux Français sur 10 disaient que leur
quotidien avait été affecté par les
mouvements de grève au mois de septembre
les trois quarts des Français disaient
que leur quotidien avait été affectés
par les grèves dans les raffineries et
là ils étaient tout à fait d'accord pour
qu'il y ait des réquisitions de
personnels quand le gouvernement la
décidait donc les Français peuvent être
assez volatils sur ces questions on sait
bien que dès qu'il y a des débordements
dans un mouvement dès que les nuisances
commencent à être important de les
Français souhaitent les arrêts des
mouvements sociaux ou du moins le
soutien sérum pour l'instant les
Français ont quand même l'air vent
debout contre le projet de réforme de
l'exécutif et a priori très consolidé
dans leur moment de contestation ouais
justement allez on va en parler c'est
l'heure de dévoiler ce sondage exclusif
au doxa pour publique Sénat et la presse
régionale on commence par l'exécutif
fiscaux on va regarder d'abord Alex vous
allez nous dire comment les Français
jugent l'attitude de l'exécutif dans la
mise en oeuvre de cette réforme
66% des Français ont une mauvaise
opinion de l'attitude d'Emmanuel Macron
dans ce débat sur la réforme des
retraites 69% d'opinions négatives
également sur l'action de la première
ministre Elisabeth borne et même chose
pour le ministre du Travail Olivier du
socle qui porte ce projet de loi de
réforme des retraites et bien il récolte
71 % de mauvaises opinions sur son
action dans cette réforme
[Musique]
j'ai envie de dire est-ce que le
gouvernement va pouvoir porter cette
réforme des retraites en étant aussi
impopulaire dans l'opinion c'est ça sur
ce point c'est que la question
maintenant elle est de la marge de
soutien dans l'opinion imprimer des
réformes pour donner une dynamique
aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron ce qu'on
voit nous dans nos mesures de popularité
c'est qu'il revient à son niveau d'avant
covid avant qu'il ne soit le président
rempart face aux crises face à la crise
sanitaire face à la crise
environnementale face à la crise
économique n'est plus le président
repart ça redevient le Emmanuel Macron
de la fin de l'année 2019 en termes de
soutien dans l'opinion et si on doit
faire d'autres parallèles historiques
Jacques Chirac avec 32% de bonnes
opinions en novembre 15 Nicolas Sarkozy
avec 30% en octobre 2010 ont connu leur
plus bas niveau de popularité quand ils
ont fait face à des mouvements sociaux
importants donc tout ce que ça montre
c'est que la séquence actuelle est
vraiment de nature à détériorer très
fortement le lien entre Emmanuel Macron
et les Français claire ça complique
considérablement la tâche de l'exécutif
ces chiffres la manière dont l'opinion
les vend on voit que là ils sont pas en
position de force pour la bataille qui
va se ranger à l'Assemblée et on sait
que les les les opposants politiques et
les syndicats comptent bien peser en
fait sur le débat parlementaire il y a
pas de majorité absolue donc ça
fragilise effectivement le gouvernement
c'est que Nicolas Sarkozy en 2010 avait
réussi à résister à une quinzaine de
mouvements sur plusieurs mois voilà mais
il avait la majorité absolue à l'époque
là ils sont présentes pas dans le même
cas de figure donc il y a une pression
en fait qui va se jouer dans la rue sur
le Parlement et c'est vrai que
l'exécutif là a perdu pas mal de points
en un mois qu'ils arrivent et donc on
voit bien que la bataille de l'opinion
et en tout cas la pédagogie ils ont
tenté de faire sur cette réforme a
échoué en fait dans cette première
séquence et puis au-delà de la notion de
popularité pour Emmanuel Macron il y a
la question de la légitimité
démocratique de cette réforme une
question qui va de plus en plus se poser
alors il a beau jeu de dire je suis
contrairement à mes prédécesseurs
Nicolas Sarkozy et Jacques Chirac le
seul président qui avait annoncé cette
réforme dans cette réforme de retraite
dans mon programme présidentiel mais il
ne faut pas oublier qu'au second tour et
bien une grande partie de ces électeurs
venez de la gauche et était contre cette
réforme il y a cette question et bien
l'opposition des Français une grande
majorité entre voilà 65 70 % son contre
la réforme des retraites actuellement et
puis il y a ce qui pourrait se passer au
Parlement ça pourrait très mal se placer
avec une utilisation de l'article 47 1
voir même de l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution c'est à dire un passage en
force sur le Parlement pour faire passer
cette réforme et là ce serait un
véritable échec démocratique pour
Emmanuel Macron ça s'apprend chez les
Français la procédure parlementaire où
ils sont loin de ces enjeux ils sont 7
sur 10 à nous dire que ce serait
inacceptable si la réforme des retraites
passait par le 49-3 et je rebondis sur
ce que ce que disait claire sur la
pédagogie cet effort de pédagogie qui a
été fait par le gouvernement c'est
vraiment un marqueur de
l'incompréhension nationale entre
l'exécutif et la population parce que
nous dans nos mesures on a des gens qui
nous disent mais finalement la pédagogie
nous on n'en veut pas parce que on a
très bien compris le projet de réforme
des retraites ont compris les tenants et
les aboutissants c'est juste qu'on en
veut pas et dès la campagne
présidentielle d'ailleurs à quoi
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé le projet de
réforme des retraites avec un report de
l'âge à 64 ou 65 ans cette Français sur
10 c'était quoi donc c'était annoncé
d'emblée et les Français ont cru un
grand moment d'horizontalité au moment
où Emmanuel Macron n'a pas eu la
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale qu'on
serait dans un moment de discussion
d'horizontalité et d'intégration des
corps intermédiaires aussi c'est là où
les syndicats peuvent jouer un rôle
utile pour les Français finalement ils
voient un projet qui est quand même
imposé de façon très verticale et qui
ils l'ont dit à maintes reprises dans
les sondages ne leur correspond pas donc
on est dans une incompréhension assez
profonde dans votre sondage on va dire
un mot d'Olivier du socle puisque c'est
lui qui a la
mauvaise côte de popularité la 71 71%
d'opinion défavorables car c'est lui qui
va porter cette réforme au Parlement et
en plus on voit qu'il est la cible de la
gauche qui les reproche ses revirements
ça va être compliqué bien sûr ben on l'a
on l'avait interviewé enfin le Dauphiné
libéré il avait intérêt récemment
puisqu'il est originaire de ces
territoires et il expliquait que il
assumait qu'il avait changé mais c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qui le
poursuit en fait le fait que vous étiez
voilà de gauche comment pouvez-vous
défendre cette cette réforme donc c'est
c'est pas évident après c'est vrai qu'on
a vu que dans la séquence Elisabeth
borne est vraiment monté au front
notamment quand elle a eu toute cette
séquence pour éviter justement le 49-3
de dire on va retourner autour de la
table on va essayer de négocier quand il
avait des questions en fait de passer
directement en force au moment du budget
et Olivier du ça parce quelque part
était un peu en retrait en fait quelque
part il est le ministre qui porte par
son portefeuille cette réforme mais
c'est vrai que ils habitent pas on était
en première ligne donc oui là il y a à
la fois le ce que vous disiez c'est
qu'il y a eu une tentative de pédagogie
sur la notion de justice on voit que ça
n'a pas imprimé les gens ont voilà alors
aujourd'hui le gouvernement abondir qui
a des fausses informations qui on voit
qu'ils se raidissent en disant bah
Elisabeth borne ça n'est pas négociable
Emmanuel Macron c'est indispensable on a
une nouvelle séquence là où on voit que
on ferme on ferme la porte à toutes négo
et on y va on y va on y va en face
quitte à recourir en 49.3
justement c'est ça c'est du coup on
arrive à une espèce d'invilli
invisibilisation du mouvement social par
l'exécutif et pour rappeler le la
contestation qui avait au premier
semestre 2016 contre la loi travail
c'est ce qui avait porté très très
fortement préjudice au gouvernement de
Manuel Valls un espèce de silence face à
la rue et d'invisibilisation du
mouvement social et là on se retrouve
dans dans ce cas de figure ce qui peut
être très préjudiciable pour le
gouvernement en termes de soutien dans
l'opinion et de crédibilité on va passer
un point peut-être plus surprenant du
sondage c'est comment les Français
jugent l'attitude des syndicats dans
cette mobilisation annexe on pourrait se
demander avec ce front syndical uni et
cette première journée de mobilisation
qui avait rassemblé entre 1 et 2
millions de personnes dans la finalement
est-ce que les syndicats vont récolter
de bonnes opinions auprès des Français
et bien la réponse est non puisque 60%
d'opinions défavorables sont perçus en
tout cas pour la CFDT de Laurent Berger
c'est pire encore pour la CGT de
Philippe Martinez avec 67 % d'opinion
des favorables les autres syndicats sur
un petit peu mieux perçus avec 40 %
d'opinion positives c'est peut-être un
peu surprenant sa Erwan comment ça
s'explique que les Français soient des
centaines de milliers à suivre l'appel
des syndicats à manifester mais
finalement ils ont une mauvaise image
oui alors on est au niveau de la cote de
popularité globale des syndicats dans
l'opinion ça c'est le premier point et
le deuxième point c'est qu'aujourd'hui
dans un paysage politique quand même qui
comporte une multitude de chapelles et
énormément de clivage avoir une cote de
popularité entre 30 et 40% on n'est pas
si mal par exemple nous dans notre
palmarès des personnalités politiques
Édouard Philippe est en tête avec 36% de
code d'adhésion donc il y a quand même
ce point à prendre en compte c'est la
grande frappe les grandes fractures qui
a dans l'opinion maintenant maintenant
c'est vrai que cette attente des
Français de corps intermédiaires elle
peut peut-être réenchanter la relation
entre les syndicats et eux dans la
défense de leur droit parce que là on
est typiquement dans une mobilisation de
défense des droits et c'est peut-être ce
qui va se passer mais le réenchantement
de cette relation on va peut-être le
voir un peu plus tard quand les Français
sont contents que les manifestations ait
eu à la différence du mouvement des
gilets jaunes une colonne vertébrale et
celle-ci elle est portée par les
syndicats évidemment claire ça peut
paraître surprenant même si Erwan
relativise en disant que finalement
entre 30 et 40 c'est pas si mal oui on
voit que Laurent Berger enfin si je me
trompe me fait partie quand même des
personnes qui ont la quelque part la
moins mauvaise party de l'opinion
négative donc quelque part il tire son
épingle du jeu peut-être par sa position
dans ce conflit ou à la fois il a tout
de suite rejeté
la réforme mais voilà amené une
discussion mais c'est vrai que personne
ne trouve grâce aux yeux des Français
dans ce conflit les opposants syndicaux
politiques il y a on voit une
fracturation qui qui ne porte pas
préjudice à la mobilisation pour le
moment parce que voilà les syndicats
vont être structurants peut-être là
pendant un temps mais leur opinion leur
volonté de combattre cette réforme qui
les concerne vraiment dans leur
quotidien dépassent en fait ce désamour
en tout cas cette distance prise avec
les syndicats et qu'on voit à chaque
élection professionnelle enfin voilà il
y a une faible participation c'est pas
dans le quotidien des Français
aujourd'hui très très important comme
dans d'autres pays européens ça reste
quand même assez distant et dans votre
sondage vous distinguez trois types de
syndicats il y a la CFDT la CGT et les
autres syndicats que vous que vous
testez ensemble et là on voit qu'il y a
quand même un écart important entre
Philippe Martinez et Laurent Berger
réformiste Philippe Martinez et beaucoup
moins bien perçu que Laurent Berger des
Français jusque l'attitude de Laurent
Berger est bonne 31% pour celle de film
Martinez il y a un écart mais qui est
l'écart qu'on retrouve entre le soutien
à la CFDT jugé plus constructif plus
arrondir les angles et la CGT plus
radicale donc ce décalage il s'explique
aussi par cette différence de de
radicalité on séduit plus largement
quand on est radical maintenant voilà
cette question elle est de dans quelle
mesure les syndicats réussissent à se
réinsérer dans une relation avec les
Français ou est-ce qu'il reste considéré
comme des vieilles machines dont on a
moins besoin que par le passé et qui
sont déconnectés du quotidien c'est tout
l'enjeu de la période aussi c'est de
replacer les syndicats dans le rôle et
ça pose aussi la question des blocages
cet écart et puis vous avez aussi et
poser la question à l'ex quelles sont
les réponses sur cette question des
blocages et oui en cas de blocages à
cause de cette mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites qui serait perçue
comme responsable de la situation et
bien seulement 35% des Français estiment
que ce serait à la responsabilité des
syndicats quatre points de moins qu'il y
a trois semaines dans un précédent
sondage et donc 64% des personnes
interrogées jugeraient que le
gouvernement serait responsable de ce
blocage c'est la photo gouvernement pour
les Français oui bah très très
significativement et on voit même que
c'est un sentiment qui est en hausse
c'est dire la légitimité populaire de la
contestation et le fait que aucun
Français ne peut être mis au banc dans
sa famille ou dans son entourage qui
conteste la réforme des retraites parce
que dans une grande mesure les Français
considèrent que s'il y avait un
embrasement ça viendrait du gouvernement
de Français sur trois on est au niveau
de soutien de la mobilisation parce que
finalement c'est une réforme qui est
venue du gouvernement qui n'est pas
concerté et du coup le rôle des
syndicats là-dedans le syndicat n'est
pas du tout vu comme un organe qui
souffle sur des braises mais le
l'embrasement viendrait vraiment du
gouvernement et ça c'est un point
important aussi et ça s'accroît depuis
la dernière journée de mobilisation du
19 janvier ça gagne trois points en deux
semaines et peut-être aussi que la
fermeté et notamment sur les 64 ans de
l'exécutif qui a été rappelé encore ce
weekend renforce ce sentiment
d'innodibilité de ce qui est proposé et
forcément ça renforce la conflictualité
aussi et le sentiment que le
gouvernement peut amener un embrasement
Emmanuel Macron qui la redit hier soir
qu'il soutenait Elisabeth borde quant à
lisait que les 64 ans n'étaient pas
négociables ça ça peut donner
l'impression comme le dit Erwan d'un
président de la République qui n'écoute
pas la rue
c'est vrai que c'est un des résultats je
voulais plus intéressants parce qu'on a
souvent enfin le gouvernement a tenté de
d'opposer les citoyens au syndicat qui
allaient être facteurs parce qu'on
disait un de gènes après avec toute la
réserve voilà de l'impact vraiment sur
la vie quotidienne des Français on a
bien compris qui pourrait avoir un
décrochage mais là effectivement le fait
que le gouvernement est d'abord dit que
au Parlement et ça pourrait être enrichi
modifié et là on a l'impression avec ces
deux séquences là de Emmanuel Macron
hier à La Haye et et Elisabeth borne ce
week-end en expliquant que rien n'était
négociable et ce durcissement de c'est
assez inaudible en fait on a
l'impression qu'il y a un changement de
pied dans la communication depuis le
début de la séquence qui fait
qu'effectivement là il y a une dynamique
qui qui se crée et on voit que le que le
gouvernement est en position de
politiquement le gouvernement ne peut
pas miser sur un retournement de
l'opinion en cas de blocage ça se
retournera contre lui c'est l'impression
qu'on a et ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur la stratégie de la pression
de la rue sur les sur les sur les
députés on sait qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement pas besoin donc s'il veut
faire passer ce texte sans avoir recours
aux 49-3 de la pointe de député LR et de
la majorité en sont dans son intégralité
on voit certains députés macronistes et
certains députés élèves vaciller sous la
pression la pression de la rue dans leur
circonscriptions il y a des voilà la
population qui vient de leur demander
des comptes et on voit que là
effectivement le gouvernement qui a
quand même essayé d'éviter ce 49 phrases
qu'on disait tout à l'heure toute la
séquence de de réouverture de ces
concertations donc thématiser avec à la
fois les opposants enfin des découpes
politiques à l'Assemblée les syndicats
ont finalement on a l'impression qu'on
revient à la case départ que toute cette
séquence a certes il y a eu un retour
sur une année on est passé de 65 à 64 il
y a eu quelques quelques jeux notamment
pour pour avoir l'appui DLR et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui ça t'a plu n'est pas
garantie pour autant donc il y a une
grande fragilité sur la séquence et
effectivement on va peut-être finalement
arriver au scénario qui avait à la
rentrée et on se dit tout ça pour ça et
donc peut-être que les Français se
disent on n'est pas entendu donc oui
c'est une des amis qui je pense pour le
gouvernement est assez devrait être
présent en compte et Claire puisque vous
parlez des partis politiques c'est la
dernière partie de ce sondage Alex
comment les Français voient l'attitude
des partis politiques oui notamment des
oppositions comment leur attitude dans
ce débat sur la réforme des retraites et
perçue et bien l'opinion des guerres
plus favorable puisque 65 % des Français
ont une mauvaise opinion du rôle joué
par le rassemblement national et c'est
pire encore pour la gauche en 72%
d'opinion des favorables concernant
l'attitude des parties de gauche qui
forment la nuque dans ce débat sur la
réforme des retraite difficile de qui
remporte la bataille de l'opposition
Erwan alors personne dans un paysage
politique vraiment fracturé non
seulement personne ne remporte la
bataille de l'opinion les Français
restent contestataires du projet en
lui-même n’identifie pas de plan B
séduisant est-ce que ça montre et c'est
aussi à la hauteur de tout ce qu'on
entend dans les témoignages des Français
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a peut-être
besoin d'une grande discussion d'une
grande réflexion nationale sur la
question du travail sur le place la
place qu'il occupe dans la vie des
Français sur la pénibilité sur
l'équilibre entre vie professionnelle et
vie personnelle toutes ces questions là
finalement qui sont soulevées par les
Français et qui ont les Français qui ont
l'impression de ne pas les retrouver
dans le projet de réforme de retraite
donc il y a peut-être ce besoin d'un
grand moment national de concertation
sur ce sujet parce que aujourd'hui en
tout cas il y a pas d'offre ni des
syndicats ni des partis politiques
d'oppositions ni de l'exécutif qui
suscite une approbation majoritaire que
l'exécutif suscite le rejet sur cette
réforme mais finalement l'opposition
d'en profite pas beaucoup pas du tout
même c'est assez enfin est-ce que vous
entendez ça je trouve ça assez et ça
montre que les gens sont assez il y a
une désorientation enfin c'est à la fois
on voit bien que Marine Le Pen a adopté
une stratégie plutôt en dehors de la rue
sans retirer son soutien voilà la
manifestation mais surtout pour ne pas
être confondu voilà avec avec la nuit
passe la nuit Pesse qui est quand même
en point dans cette stratégie à la fois
d'obstruction plus raisonnable qu'en
2019 et de de voilà de de mobilisation
dans la rue qui n'en tire pas non plus
profit donc l'assemblée qu'on a vu
émerger après la présidentielle qui
était vraiment inédite dans sa
configuration on voit aujourd'hui que
personne finalement ne bénéficie de sa
stratégie politique pour pour venir
contester ce texte et que même les LR
qui avaient quand même été élu sur un
projet de réforme se retrouve à la
contester aujourd'hui donc c'est vrai
que c'est pas facile quand même de s'y
retrouver pour conclure à Roanne ça
illus finalement une crise de la
représentativité votre sondage oui c'est
ça en tout cas que il y a pas de
d'aspiration majoritaire à suivre un
projet en particulier ce qui est
exprimait très très clairement c'est que
le projet de réforme tel qu'il est
proposé aujourd'hui ne séduit pas les
Français je pense qu'ils sont assez
résolu sur ce point là c'est vraiment le
point important c'est que les Français
sont résolus à ce que ce projet ne passe
pas en l'état c'est l'ampleur de la
contestation maintenant s'il y avait un
nouveau projet il devrait être discuté
et concerté parce que en l'état il n'y a
pas de plan B séduisant dans l'opinion
merci beaucoup
Erwan lescend merci Claire Planchard
d'être venu nous parler de cette
mobilisation et de ce sondage au doxa
pour Public Sénat et la presse régionale
merci beaucoup merci Alex claire j'ai
choisi vous avez de nombreux titres j'ai
choisi une une celle des Dernières
Nouvelles d'Alsace j'espère que ça vous
ira qu'elle mobilisation c'est à la Une
des DNA merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous merci à tous de nous avoir suivis
merci aux équipes techniques qui ont
permis la réalisation de cette émission
se retrouve demain très bonne journée
[Musique]